usually having a certain weight and then
when I went off TV there's a period
there of just like cheese popcorn slow
hello job television job 3 at time
sometimes I'm so mad I can't read if
there's ever been a time in my life to
just say to hell with it it's now they
started out as a small idea we're going
to just go out there and put on show for
thy own show again push this crowd back
everyone give me some room get these
people back
no no photo should I be worried that
we're opening in a town where nobody
lives
this is a cool opportunity for me this
is my opportunity to tell you who I am
how I grew up and how I came to be do
you want to hear this story it's a
pretty good story
oh wait that's an article there about
[Laughter]
[Music]
what happened to us and II walked away
from the greatest franchise in history
because I refused to go on @midnight
I am on @midnight so far so good
it's not the show it's the interviews
right after the show that are killing me
thank you shut up no one's thinking
about burning me out people that
actually maybe arrangement are never
here the best show in Canada this
thing's it's free and right you know
what I want to do not talk to hundred
people I'd like somebody to help me but
I lose my voice we're done line got no
defense against this one
[Music]
stop stop
okay and you want me to sign your back
ah paparazzi
[Music]
you